Here are 2 materials, that as you rotate them, it doesn't really change how
they reflect the light. Here's a material where it does. As you rotate it, the
light reflects in different ways. The second kind of material is called
anisotropic. Compared to isotropic, which is how most materials are. Good
examples of anisotropic materials are. Brushed aluminum and velvet. A simple
wave making a material anisotropic is to give the object a pair of normals
instead of a single normal. In this exercise you start off with our energy
balance to blend on reflection model for a plane. What I want you to do is
change the single normal to be two normals as if the material has grooves in
it. If you look closely at the fragment shader, you'll see I cheat a bit. I
take the fragment's location and use its x and z position to make these new
normals. I can do this because I know the original normal is mostly pointing up
the y axis. Your job is to take these two normals and use them instead of the
original normal. Basically you need to apply the reflection model twice, once
to each normal. To keep things about the same intensity, make both of these
contributions be each just half as strong. I'd like to point out that GLSL has
the idea of a loop built into it. This should prove handy for this exercise.
Here's the result which, even though it's a hack, looks pretty nice I don't
mind saying. Remember, the major rule of graphics is it just has to look right.
One thing to keep in mind, the groove parameter, when set to zero, should give
a result exactly the same as the original reflection model. If it doesn't
you'll need to figure out what to fix.